>>Jeff Hamilton: Nick Okay. Hi, everybody.
Welcome to how to NFC.
My name is Jeff Hamilton, and I'm an engineer
on the Android team working on the NFC stack.
>>Nick Pelly: And my name is Nick Pelly. I'm
also a software engineer on the Android team,
working on the NFC stack.
I also want to introduce you to Ben Dodson,
who is an intern on the Android team and will
be helping with the demos.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Before we get started, we'd
like to point out -- hold on a second. We
lost the slides here.
>>Nick Pelly: Should we switch to the other
box?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yeah.
Okay. Before we get started, we'd just like
to point out real quick we have some links
for feedback for the presentation. If you'd
like to give feedback on how we're doing up
here. Also, we have some hashtags if you're
going to be tweeting about the talk, you can
see up here, IO2011 and Android. We're going
to take some live questions from the audience
as well as from Google Moderator. If you have
questions that come up during the talk, you
can put them in online, or if you're watching
the live stream, feel free to put questions
in there and we'll get to those at the end
of the talk.
So we're going to talk today about, you know,
first, what is NFC.
Second, we're going to talk about why use
NFC and why this is relevant to you as developers
to add to your applications.
Third, we're going to talk briefly about how
to NFC 101, just kind of an intro to NFC on
Android and what you can do as developers
to add NFC support to your applications.
Fourth, we're going to talk to how to NFC
201 and deep dive a little bit more into the
details of the technology.
So first, what is NFC?
Just a quick show of hands, how many people
in the audience are familiar with what NFC
is?
Wow.
>>Nick Pelly: That's a lot.
>>Jeff Hamilton: That's quite a lot of you.
Now we'd like to do a quick show of hands.
How many of the developers out there have
added NFC support to their applications.
>>Nick Pelly: We've got to change this.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Quite a few of hands were
up for the first question, not for the second.
We're hoping by the end of this talk, you'll
have the information you need to add NFC support
to your applications.
So just real quick, what is NFC? It stands
for Near Field Communications. And it's a
wireless technology similar to Bluetooth or
Wi-Fi where you can transmit data wirelessly.
Unlike Bluetooth or Wi-Fi, it has very short
range. So the theoretical maximum is about
ten centimeters. On a smartphone, you're going
to see closer to one to four centimeters typical
range for interactions.
NFC is also typically low speed. So you're
going to get between your configurations,
106 to maybe 414 kilobits per second. That's
kilobits, not kilobytes. That kind of depends
on your configuration as well as -- these
are theoretical maximum numbers. You might
see lower speeds than that.
So those two properties, you know, don't really
compare to Bluetooth or Wi-Fi. But what's
really great about NFC is it's a low-friction
setup. So because it's -- only works at short
range, anytime you bring two devices that
support NFC within that range, they're going
to set up a connection and be ready to talk
to each other. So there's no discovery like
you have in Bluetooth. There's no pairing.
You don't have to put in passwords or anything
like that. This is really, we think, a magical
property of NFC that really makes it kind
of a science fiction type of technology. Things
just work.
Additionally, NFC supports what is called
passive targets. These are devices that do
NFC, but they don't have batteries in them.
These are things like stickers or random devices
that aren't powered, can support NFC. There's
a tiny microcontroller with an antenna, and
it picks up the power from a secondary device
and actually powers up the device from another
one. So you can interact with things in the
world and they don't need power. And that's
a really interesting property of NFC that
doesn't exist in any other technology. And
we think it really enables, you know, interesting
applications for, you know, the technology
and great things that people can do with it.
Off to Nick.
>>Nick Pelly: Jeff's talked a little bit about
the basic properties of NFC. And, hopefully,
some of you in the audience have some ideas
of how you can use these properties to build
awesome applications.
Today, we want to make the case to you of
why NFC is going to be so compelling to users.
Why should you care about NFC?
Well, we like to think of it as bridging the
physical and the virtual worlds. Now, this
is a kind of cheesy saying. But, you know,
this is really true. With NFC and low proximity,
you can bring two devices next to each other
and it will trigger a virtual reaction. Physical
actions, virtual reactions.
This is something that we haven't seen from
any other wireless technology. Bluetooth,
Wi-Fi, you don't have that easy connection
setup. This is new to NFC, and we think users
are going to love it.
Let us show some demonstrations.
So first, basic tag read. You may already
be familiar with this, but we're going to
show it anyway. Everyone has a Google I/O
badge. And inside it, you've got your NFC
sticker. I've got one of them here right now.
So you may have already tried this with your
Nexus S. If not, let me show you how easy
it is to read content off of this tag.
You take your Nexus S, if I get the right
phone. At the home screen, and just touch
it to the tag. (chime).
There you go. I've read Jeff's contact details.
That's the V card. So these are stickers,
you can start thinking about where you might
want to place these stickers. A useful one
for Jeff would probably be on his front.
So we can now tap Jeff and read his contact
details.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Come see me after the talk.
[ Laughter ]
>>Nick Pelly: So these stickers don't need
any power. They're inexpensive, they're becoming
cheaper. You can think of them a little like
QR codes. You can embed basic data onto them.
Let's now go to a few more demonstrations
of the kind of content you can put on an NFC
tag.
We're going to switch to the demo board, where
we have a number of tags embedded into the
board so that we can quickly tap different
areas and show you the NFC content in the
tags.
These tags could just as easily be a sticker
or a card or any other form factor.
Ben's going to just tag a few of these and
show how easy it is to read content.
The first one had a URL. Android.com, the
Wi-Fi's a little slow -- there we are. It's
coming up. (chime).
The next one has another V card. And then
the next one should have some text. (chime).
So, hopefully, you're getting the idea. We
can put URLs, text, contact, in fact, any
MIME data type into a tag. And most importantly,
when you touch the phone to the tag, it doesn't
matter where you are, it doesn't matter that
you don't have any application running. You
can be at the home screen, and it will take
you to the right application to handle that
content. That's really powerful. QR codes
don't do that.
Let's do a direct comparison, actually, of
NFC versus QR codes.
This is a little bit unfair, but let's just
do it to see the difference in speed.
So Jeff is going to try and read a Google
PLACES location embedded in a tag by scanning.
While Ben is going to read it from a QR code.
Three, two, one, go. (chime).
>>Nick Pelly: And the NFC tag's already done.
It's a little bit unfair to QR. You have to
fire up the application and focus the camera.
Good luck if you're in low light conditions.
So the key point here, NFC is just really
fast. It's low friction. We think users are
going to love it.
And you can see the sequence with QRs.
So let's now go to an application that we
put together in just a few days. We have APIs
for NFC read, write, and peer-to-peer that
are already a part of the Gingerbread platform
today. So we've used these APIs to put together
an application called Sticky Notes. It's just
a very simple application to, you know, show
you how easy it is to use.
Ben is going to tag this phone to some text
and it's going to automatically launch the
Sticky Notes application. That's it. It's
read the content. We can now show you that
it can actually write content to these tags
as well. This is something we haven't mentioned
yet. These tags are reprogrammable. They are
a -- they have their own microprocessor. It's
not like a QR code. You can actually program
these things once they're already deployed.
So can we get, like, a word or a phrase that
you want to put into a tag here? We can demonstrate
it live.
Chicken. Okay.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Chicken it is.
>>Nick Pelly: That was really quick.
We have a lively audience.
Okay. Ben's programmed it into the tag to
prove we're not faking it. Jeff is going to
use a different phone to read it back out.
And note it's going to launch the Sticky Notes
application again.
>>Jeff Hamilton: There we go.
>>Nick Pelly: That's it. It's just so easy.
So now the third mode --
[ Applause ]
>>Jeff Hamilton: There we go.
>>Nick Pelly: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Pelly: The third that's really interesting
is peer-to-peer. Yep, you can read or write
to these passive stickers, and, yeah, there
are plenty of other peer-to-peer protocols,
Bluetooth, Wi-Fi. What makes NFC so interesting
is that it's triggered by the proximity, so
you don't need to go fumbling around in any
UI. You just put the two phones together.
What we have is the two phones, both in the
Sticky Notes application, both with different
text contents. With the Nexus S, the antennas
are in the back of the phone, so you place
them back to back. (chime).
And they've exchanged content. That's it.
You don't need to go fumbling around in any
menus.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Pelly: We're going to show some more
peer-to-peer demos, and we're going to do
it using the demo board. There's the outline
of two Nexus S phones on here. They have actually
got antennas hard-wired behind them so that
we can show you the front of both phones as
we do peer-to-peer. But if you're trying this
at home, you're going to want to put the phones
back to back.
So we hope that you're beginning to see some
of the possibilities of this technology.
What we wanted to do was just throw together
some demos of -- some more sort of sci-fi,
like, what can this proximity-triggered action
enable.
We wanted to create a wormhole. We programmed
two tags to be the end points of this wormhole.
You can imagine that one tag is in Australia;
one tag is in San Francisco. And when you
place one phone on the first tag, it begins
the wormhole. (chime).
>>Nick Pelly: And on this other tag. (chime).
We've taken a risk with these demos. We have
NFC, Bluetooth, and Wi-Fi at a conference.
So the Wi-Fi is a bit slow.
But what's going to happen in a decent Wi-Fi
connection is you're going to have a video
chat complete and you can be talking to someone
on the other side of the world just through
touching the phones to a tag.
>>Jeff Hamilton: One more time. (chime).
Some people claim wormholes don't exist.
>>Nick Pelly: I guess Einstein was right.
All right. Let's go to another demo.
So we have worked with Halfbrick Studios and
in just a few days, we took the Fruit Ninja
application and added NFC and Bluetooth to
make it head-to-head multiplayer. Head-to-head
multiplayer games over Bluetooth is not really
new, but what is new is using NFC to initiate
the connection.
So we have one phone at the Fruit Ninja menu
screen. The other phone can be anywhere. It's
just at the home screen right now. Put them
together and see what happens. (chime).
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Pelly: That's it, straight into a game.
Isn't that awesome?
It looks like our intern has been practicing
this one.
>>Jeff Hamilton: He's pretty good.
>>Nick Pelly: I want to be clear, everything
we've shown you is possible with Gingerbread
APIs. This can all be done today. We're going
to make it easier for developers with some
additional APIs in Ice Cream. But the functionality
is already there.
Let's talk a little bit more about Ice Cream
Sandwich.
I hope you're already convinced that NFC is
an interesting technology. And we really hope
that we've got your imagination going with
the kinds of activities that you can build
out of this physical interaction.
We think it's really interesting, too, and
we think this is just the tip of the iceberg.
Here are some ideas that we're going to put
into the Ice Cream Sandwich release.
We want to really focus on these 0-click interactions.
We keep coming back to the one-key feature.
You can put two phones together without any
UI, without having to launch any application,
and share content.
So we're going to bring 0-click sharing into
the platform for Ice Cream Sandwich.
Let's show some demonstrations.
Ben is viewing a contact. You put the other
phone next to it, and immediately, it just
shares that contact. This is how easy it should
be.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Pelly: It's sharing the on-screen contact
with the other phone.
Let's go to a Web page. Ben is going to load
a Web page. Android.com. Put it against another
phone, and -- (chime) -- as you can guess,
it just loads the Web page.
We want to build this into as many system
apps as we can. And we want to make the APIs
for this easily available to application developers
for use with your applications.
So there's one more demo that we want to show.
We don't have NFC in a tablet yet, but we
have hacked up this tablet with an NFC evaluation
board.
[ Laughter ]
>>Nick Pelly: To show you, you know, what
can be possible when we have a broader range
of devices available with NFC.
Let's say you're watching YouTube on a Nexus
S. It's got a great screen, but the tablet
is so much better. Here's what we think should
happen when you touch your YouTube video to
the tablet.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Pelly: And if you noticed, it resumes
playback right where the other one left off.
>>Jeff Hamilton: If only I could dance that
well.
>>Nick Pelly: So we hope we have you excited.
There's one more demo that we think the application
developers in the audience are going to be
particularly excited about. And that is application
sharing.
So let's say that one phone is running Fruit
Ninja. The other phone doesn't have Fruit
Ninja installed. What should happen when you
put those two phones together?
Well, let's demonstrate.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Let's see.
(chime).
>>Nick Pelly: There you go. Take you to the
market to download it. This is going to encourage
viral app sharing. If you and your friends
you want to share an app to a friend, you
don't have to go search to it in the market.
You can just touch your phone to theirs and
they can download it.
I will now pass back to Jeff for how to NFC.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Thanks, Nick. Those were
some great demos.
So we have seen a little bit about what you
can do with NFC, what the technology is like.
And hopefully you all are starting to think
about what kinds of things you can do in your
applications using NFC.
Let's talk a bit about how you would do that.
First we're going to talk quickly about how
to read data over NFC. Then we're going to
talk how to write data over NFC. And then
we're going to get into some more advanced
topics at the end.
The first thing to know when reading data
from NFC is that there's a data structure
called NDEF, this stands for NFC Data Exchange
Format. It is the data container format to
use for NFC.
The reason that there needs to be a standardized
data container format here is that on the
passive tags, there's a lot of different types
of technology that exist, and they all have
a lot of different properties, different ways
they store data on them, and things like that.
So the standard NDEF here is designed to be
able to work across all of these different
types of technologies. And it's just a way
you can interact with NFC devices and be guaranteed
that you're going to have a common data structure
across these devices for many different vendors.
The general structure of NDEF is, first you
have a message, and the message encapsulates
within it one or more NDEF records.
And the message is just an encapsulation of
records. The records that you have in there,
each record has a high level type, and then
there's optionally a second level type that's
scoped within the first level type. There's
an optional ID within the record. And then
there's an optional payload as well.
For more information about NDEF messages and
NDEF records, the NDEF message and NDEF record
classes in the SDK, there's a bunch of documentation
there with the gory details.
>>Nick Pelly: NDEF was the contain format
we used for each of those demos.
>>Jeff Hamilton: The first thing to know about
NDEF when reading it on the phone is how it's
going to be dispatched to your application.
So by design, the NFC data is dispatched to
only one activity on the phone. And we think
this is actually a very important aspect of
the way we design the system. Because when
users are interacting with things with NFC,
they really are looking for instant gratification
for the way that they're interacting with
things around them in space. And so what we
really wanted to do is launch directly into
the application that handles the data that
they're interacting with. And we really think
that, you know, for the best experience for
the user, going directly to the application
is very important so that they can interact
with things around them.
So let's talk a bit about how you get into
your activity when data is read over NDEF.
So what we do is we take the first NDEF record
in the NDEF message and we look at its type.
And we build an intent from that type.
So this slide shows some examples of how we
are going to take an NDEF and convert it into
an intent. And we show that on the right-hand
side with some snippets from an Android manifest
file, and this is how you would capture NDEF
data coming into the phone from your activity.
So the first two examples show how we handle
just raw text coming in. So the Sticky Notes
example we showed earlier handles text plain
line type, and it just deals with general
text.
So there are two ways you can get general
text. There is a top-level type well-known
with a secondary type of text, and the payload
is just text.
The second one is you can have MIME data in
an NF record, so if you have MIME data and
the secondary type is text plain, the payload
again would be just text. And what we do is
we take the MIME type there, text plain, and
we put that on the MIME type field for the
intent that we start when the data comes in,
and that let's applications filter on the
different types of data they are interested
in.
So taking that a step further, the third example
here is using the application slash VND.example
and this is the generally accepted format
of doing vendor specific MIME codes or MIME
types.
So this is something we think would be great
for developers. If you have a data structure
you want to put in a sticker or you want to
transfer over peer to peer, you can just create
your own custom MIME type using VND dot and
then your domain name and put your payload
in there.
What we do is we take that MIME type, put
it into the intent and from your Android manifest
you can specify you want that MIME type coming
in from NDEF, and then your application will
get launched directly to handle your data
structures.
And the last example, we can do basically
the same thing using a URI. So there are three
different ways you can store URIs in NDEF.
If we find one of those three ways, we pull
the URI out, and we set that as the data field
on the intent, and you can use the existing
standard Android manifest matching mechanism
for saying which URIs you are interested in.
And you can be as specific or generic as you
want when setting up that match in the system.
>>Nick Pelly: You can think of NDEF types
as like a superset of MIME and URL types,
and Android does the work for you in mapping
those to MIME or URL types for intent filters.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Okay. So now we talked a
little bit about how we build that intent,
let's look at some code snippets for how applications
would actually handle that.
The first one we have here is the Android
manifest from the Sticky Notes example we
showed earlier, and it's just an extra intent
filter that has the action NDEF discovered
on there. And this one, for the Sticky Notes,
was looking for text, so it set the MIME type
to text plain.
Here you would just put in, in this intent
filter, you would put in some kind of filter
there for whatever data type you have that
your application is dealing with over NFC.
The second code snippet we have here is just
the activity and how it would handle it when
it receives that intent. There's basically
just an extra on the intent, it's called extra
NDEF messages and that's an array of NDEF
messages. Typically there's only one NDEF
message that comes over the payload, but it
is an array because it is possible in some
cases to have multiple NDEF messages. So typically
you just look at the first NDEF in that array,
get that NDEF record in there and off you
go.
>>Nick Pelly: This code snippet is straight
from the Sticky Notes application that we
demonstrated, and the full code is available,
is linked at the end of the presentation.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Let's talk a bit about best
practices when dealing with NFC and NDEF data.
I think this is very important that you always
want to use precise intent filters. You don't
just want to say I capture URIs that all have
HTTP as their scheme because if multiple applications
are doing that, you are going to get something
like we have in the slides here where you
have an activity chooser dialogue, and the
user is really not going to have that instant
gratification that we think is the hallmark
of NFC and what makes the technology really
exciting for users, and it's not going to
be a great experience for them.
So we highly suggest that you structure your
data in ways that you can create precise intent
filters with custom MIME types or with URIs
to domains that you control so you are not
going to be stepping on each other toes, and
it will be the best experience for all the
users out there.
Another thing worth mentioning as well we
talked earlier about how NFC is kind of slow
on the data transfer rate, so we also recommend
that you keep your data structures on the
smaller side. Typically, one kilobyte or less
is a good recommendation.
>>Nick Pelly: Please, no XML over NFC.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Okay. So we talked about
reading NDEF. Now let's talk about where you
can read it from.
So you can read it from passive tags, as we
showed in the demos earlier. There are a bunch
of different types of passive tags. So the
NFC forum has gone out there and they specified
four standardized types of passive tags. They
are called type 1 through 4.
We have up here some examples of products
that implement these specifications. These
are the most common implementations of these
specifications that you find out there, although
they are not the only implementations that
exist. There is the Topaz, type 1; MIFARE
Ultralight, type 2; Sony Felica, type 3; and
MIFARE Desfire, type 4.
Outside of the NFC forum defined types, there
are also some proprietary NFC tags Micro classic
is the best example of that. There is tons
of micro classics out there in the world today,
and they support NDEF as well.
Because they are completely standardized,
support for those is optional in Android.
Not all devices are necessarily going to be
able to read these tags. The Nexus S can read
them, but if you are putting a deployment
out there in the world, we highly suggest
you go with one of the standard type 1 through
4 tags because then you will be guaranteed
that all devices will be able to read them
and you won't run into any problems with people
who have devices that can't read the type
of tag you have deployed.
And last but not least, you can read NDEF
peer to peer. And this is from one Android
phone to another. And we think that's a very
exciting way to read it as well.
So we talked earlier about NFC stickers. I
think you have all probably seen these in
your badge sheaths. The stickers we have given
you are type 4 tags that can hold up to two
kilobytes of data in them. If you read the
sticker in there with the Nexus S, it will
take you to a Web page that has a link to
documentation about NFC, some sample code
from Sticky Notes application, as well as
a link to the NXP tag writer application from
our friends at NXP, and you can download that
from the marketplace and you can use it to
rewrite the tag and play with it and put whatever
data you want in there.
One thing to note, these tags are rewritable
so you can put whatever data structures you
want in. There you can play around with them,
use them to develop applications. But beware
that you can't make them read only. So if
you are going to put them up, stick them around
somewhere, be aware that someone might come
around and rewrite them on you and who knows
what they will put in there.
Keep Nick away from your tags.
Okay. So let's talk a bit about writing in
more detail.
As we said, NDEF tags can be writable. It's
also possible to configure the tags to be
read only from the factor tree when you purchase
them. The type 1 and 2 tags it's possible
to make read only at any time. If you had
a read/writable tag, you can mark it read
only and that will be honored in the tag.
For types 3 and 4 they have to be configured
as read only from the factory. So if you get
a read/writable tag like the ones we've given
you guys today, you can't mark that tag read
only later on. So that's something to be aware
of if you are looking to deploy tags out in
the field.
So when you go to write tags programmatically
on Android, you have to do that when the tag
is in the field of the phone. So that's when
the tag is touching the phone, pretty much.
And we have a code snippet here, again from
our Sticky Notes sample code. You can go down
to the sample code on the Web page. Basically
you just create an NDEF record that has the
text that you want to write into it, encapsulate
that in a NDEF message, and then get a reference
to the tag object that you want to write to
and the NDEF technology you are going to use
to write, and then just call write NDEF message
and it goes out over to the tag and you are
good to go.
So writing peer to peer is a little different.
The way we set it up on Android is only the
foreground activity can register a payload
to push over a peer-to-peer link.
So the application needs to register that
payload in advance. It's something that we
think is really important in the way the APIs
are set up, because we want to make sure the
user is aware of which activity is using the
NFC radio.
>>Nick Pelly: I think it's a common theme
about APIs, actually. We always want to encourage
the foreground activity to be the one using
NFC. It's for instant gratification so the
user knows exactly which application is using
the NFC link.
>>Jeff Hamilton: So your application on resume
we just call the NFC adapter, or API enable
foreground NDEF push. And you head off an
NDEF message. So what happens then is the
system will take that NDEF message, and when
a peer-to-peer link is established, it will
hand that NDEF message over to the other phone
on the end of the peer-to-peer link, and it
will dispatch that NDEF message as if it had
been read from a passive tag.
>>Nick Pelly: You can use the same code on
the receiving side for peer to peer as you
used for reading a passive tag. It looks the
same. You just receive a NDEF payload.
>>Jeff Hamilton: So this is a really nice
API, we think. It makes it very easy to add
peer-to-peer support for NFC on your applications.
You just need to call enable foreground NDEF
push from your on resume and hand off the
content.
One thing we thought would be handy on the
API, and unfortunately we didn't get it into
Gingerbread, we will add this in Ice Cream
Sandwich, is you can add a callback system
-- you can register a callback. So when the
peer-to-peer link is brought up, there will
be a call back made to your application and
you can return a NDEF message at that time
that's relevant to the state of your application
when the link is established.
So that's something you saw earlier with the
YouTube example. The YouTube application on
the phone is using this Ice Cream Sandwich
API, and it's responding with not only a link
to the video that its playing back but also
the time stamp of where it is in that video
so the other side can start playback at the
same point.
>>Nick Pelly: Okay. So Jeff's covered the
basics of how to NFC. And we really focused
on NDEF tag read, NDEF tag write, and NDEF
peer to peer. There's a theme here. We're
talking about NDEF. But are all NFC tags NDEF?
Well, they are not. So we are going to go
into detail about the NFC ecosystem on a broader
level. Don't worry, we are not going to go
too deep. There's a lot to talk about here
but we will just make you aware of some of
the things that you should know.
So NFC as a technology has actually been around
for over 15 years. But NDEF is a fairly new
standardization. And over that 15 years, companies
have invested heavily into NFC for transit,
for credit cards, for passports, for physical
access cards. There's over 5 billion of these
already out there that your Nexus S or other
Android NFC phone can talk to already.
Now is probably a good time to bring up RFID.
We haven't mentioned it yet. RFID is a different
technology to NFC and it really bugs me because
I keep reading articles where they replace
NFC with RFID. They are different set of technologies.
RFID is typically working at a range of meters.
NFC is exclusively a centimeter range technology.
This is really important. This means that
you were going to get that proximity triggered
interaction, physical reactions, virtual reactions.
And it means that you don't have to worry
so much about many devices being in the field
or privacy and security.
Anyway, so when we quote the 5 billion number,
that's 5 billion NFC tags.
So this is our crazy diagram of like all the
different NFC technologies that -- actually,
it's a subset of the technologies that have
been out there for the last 15 years. When
we rehearsed this, I can talk for half an
hour about all these technologies, but my
product manager was like, no, let's just spend
30 seconds.
So all I want to do is let you guys know there
are a bunch of different technologies that
are all sort of -- fall under the NFC ecosystem.
And all those tags that are deployed that
are non-NDEF are going to use one of these
technologies.
Now, the good news for you guys today is we
have built APIs to the majority of these technologies
so that you can read and write with all of
these legacy tags that are already out there
today.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Pelly: So I won't go into the detail,
but if you want to look into using these classes,
the package is android.NFC.technology. We
have a set of classes like IsoDep, NfcA, NfcB,
NfcF. If you know NFC well, you might have
heard of some of these before. And we have
all the low-level commands you need. You know,
transceive, authenticate, read, write, to
use all of these technologies from your Android
applications.
So I will mention that when I say technologies,
I kind of mean protocol. Any given tag can
have an RF level protocol and then one or
more other protocols building on top. So don't
be surprised when you see multiple technologies
enumerate on a single tag.
Now, we talked about dispatching to application
with NDEF. We use the NDEF discovered intent.
It's a start activity intent so we always
are bringing an application to the foreground.
It's the same with non-NDEF tags. We use the
tech discovered intent, it's a start activity
intent. We are trying to bring the application
to the foreground so the user gets instant
gratification.
The content you filter on is no longer the
NDEF type because we don't know the type.
It's some unknown tag with different technologies
on it. So instead you filter on the technologies
you want to use.
So, for example, if you are writing an application
to read information off of a transit card,
you might specify that you are looking for
cards with NfcA and IsoDep because you know
all the transit cards you care about have
those technologies.
>>Jeff Hamilton: I think it's worth noting
it happens before the technology phase.
So if you're writing an application and you're
using NDEF and you're using the intent filters
like we described earlier for NDEF data, that's
going to happen before the technology discovered
happens.
So, basically, we call start activity if we
get any results back for activities that handle
that NDEF data structure. We just launch directly
into them. If there are no activities installed
in the system that handle that NDEF data structure,
then we'll go on and try to dispatch and call
start activity on action tech discovered with
the technologies that are present on the tag
that's in the field.
So if you're using NDEF, that takes precedent
over the technology level. We think that's
kind of important, because NDEF allows much
more precise filtering to applications, and,
you know, that's a great way to get directly
into your application for a better user experience.
>>Nick Pelly: Please use NDEF if you can.
But if you can't because you're using legacy
tags, then look at tech discovered.
While we're talking about dispatching tags
to your applications, there's one other important
dispatch mechanism we want to mention.
We have an API function, enable foreground
dispatch.
When your activity is already in the foreground,
you can call this to tell the Android operating
system that you want to receive all further
tags into your application and not some other
application. You know, this is really important,
because otherwise, if you're trying to write
to a tag from your application and then you
scan a tag, you can make sure that you're
not going to launch to some other third-party
application. It's going to stay in your application
and you can receive all the new tag updates.
So this is a good tip to look at enable foreground
dispatch.
Okay, I just talked a whole bunch about passive
tags, reading and writing. Let's talk a little
bit deeper about peer-to-peer.
The key feature of NFC for peer-to-peer is
that it's low friction. There's no discovery,
there's no pairing. You just touch the phones
together and it will launch the application.
However, it's got a low range. It's only going
to work when they're sort of one to four centimeters
away. That's not great for playing a multiplayer
game. And the data rate is really slow.
So like with the Fruit Ninja demo, we really
recommend to switch to a high-bandwidth connection
like Bluetooth, or you can equally well use
Wi-Fi, or even go through the cloud for your
heavy lifting in the application.
Bluetooth and NFC, they go together so well.
We really recommend you look at this.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Wireless nirvana.
>>Nick Pelly: NFC to initiate the connection,
and then Bluetooth for the -- the heavy lifting.
Please don't do socket-style communication
with NFC. It doesn't work so well.
Okay. We're getting towards the end. We just
want to recap on the key points that we've
presented to you today.
Number one, I think we've said it a few times
now, but just to hammer it home, NFC is quick
connection setup is what it's about. So please
think about how you can use this in your applications
and the kinds of experiences your users are
going to get out of this.
Number two, you can work with passive devices,
stickers, tags. You can take these stickers
and just, you know, place them around the
environment, on people, and just, you know,
see what happens.
NDEF dispatch, use precise intent filters
and prefer NDEF over the legacy technologies.
Number four is, foreground interaction. The
APIs are designed to work in the foreground.
So, you know, we really don't want to encourage
applications to be using the NFC connection
in the background.
And lastly, for socket-style communication,
please use Bluetooth or some other, you know,
higher-range connection.
We're about to go to Q&A, but I want to just
cover a few topics we know are going to come
up first.
Privacy. So, you know, when we work with NFC,
we often hear people talking about privacy.
And, you know, it's a really important topic
to discover. Because we do care about user
privacy. I don't want people reading my contact
information out of my phone without me letting
them. So I want to touch on a few points.
First of all, NFC is not RFID. It does not
work at a range of meters. This is a centimeter
technology. You have to be really close to
the phone in order to communicate with the
NFC antenna. It's a very low-powered antenna.
Second point is, yeah, NFC is off when the
screen is off. So, you know, as I like to
call it, there's no butt-sniffing. You can't
go and scan someone while their phone's in
their back pocket and the screen's off.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jeff Hamilton: That's a good thing. You
don't want Nick doing that to you.
>>Nick Pelly: I thought you took that out
of the slides.
And lastly, third-party applications, they
must be in the foreground. We really think
this is the right usage model. It's instant
gratification. And it means that you know
which applications are using the NFC link
and you know if they're misbehaving.
Okay. Second hot topic is security. It's related
to privacy, and some of the important points
are similar.
NFC is, by design, low range and low power.
So if someone was to try and intercept or
eavesdrop on a communication, they're going
to be need to be very close in order to see
what's going on.
Now, that said, there is no link-level encryption
built into the standard NFC protocols. So
if you care deeply about the payload, if the
payload is a financial instrument or something
else that you need to keep secure, then you
should encrypt it or you should look at some
of the more advanced NFC technologies that
do have encryption built into the lower level.
But by default, don't assume that the link
level is encrypted.
Lastly, card emulation. This is the most popular
question on Android developers' Google Groups.
So we talked a lot about reader/writer mode
and peer-to-peer. There's a third major mode
of NFC, which is card emulation. This is when
the Nexus S is pretending to be a passive
tag that you can put in the field of a reader/writer.
So if you wanted to pretend to be a transit
card or pretend to be a credit card. So in
Gingerbread, we have no API support for card
emulation. And it's not that we forgot. We
thought very hard about it. But there's some
simple reasons.
I showed you that diagram earlier of all those
different technologies. Well, if you're going
to do card emulation, the hardware has to
pick one of those technologies to emulate.
You can't typically emulate all of them at
the same time. And the hardware out there
today doesn't actually support all of these
at the same time anyway.
So if we were to build these APIs, the applications
are going to have a really inconsistent experience
as they're deployed to different Android devices.
Some will support NFC A, some will support
NFC B. We don't think this is really going
to be a great story for third-party developers
right now.
And secondly, when you're doing card emulation,
you're emulating a passive target that is
going to have one kilobyte, two kilobytes
of memory. You're going to then have to decide
which application has the right to manage
this limited resource.
So we did not put card emulation APIs in Gingerbread
because we want to make sure that we have
a compelling user story before we do that.
And we really think that peer-to-peer is the
way to go for future NFC uses. Peer-to-peer
and NDEF, because with NDEF you can filter
on content. And with peer-to-peer, it's a
newer technology. It doesn't have to assume
that one side is passive.
So that's it for the main part of the presentation.
We encourage you to go to NFC.android.com.
We have links to the sample code for Sticky
Notes, links to the developer APIs. And you
can give us feedback on how we went today
at the feedback link. You can tweet about
this with the hashtags. And we're going to
now take questions from the audience live,
and also, you can post questions online at
the last link.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Pelly: Okay, can we get the first question
live, in the brown shirt.
>>> So what can you tell us about your plans
for other devices that support -- that will
support NFC in the near future, other than
the Nexus S?
>>Nick Pelly: Well, I think, you know, it's
up to the OEMs. You know, I think they are
going to want to -- they would love to see
more applications in the market. So it's kind
of up to you guys to write some really great
applications out there that really, you know,
make the OEMs see the use cases for NFC. Yeah,
and, you know, we do know personally of dozens
of phones in the pipeline for 2011 that are
going to have NFC. So don't worry, they will
come as well.
>>> Thank you.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Take a question from the
back mike, please.
>>> So are there intents, then, to update
all of the standard apps, contacts, GMail,
the browser, to have a standard NDEF payload
that they're just showing all the time?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yes. So that's something
that we showed off in the Ice Cream Sandwich
preview. That's something we're going to look
at adding in the Ice Cream Sandwich platform.
You know, in the demos that we showed, like,
from contacts, it's exporting a standard V
card. So it's a MIME type, which is V card.
So that's a pretty big standard there. URIs
come through just as a URI. There's an NDEF
specification for how to store URIs, so those
come through just like that. So NDEF as a
format covers pretty much all the data structures
that we'd export. And for things like contacts,
we just go with the standards like V card.
>>> All right. So Ice Cream Sandwich is when
we'd start to see that just show up in the
standard apps?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yeah, in the platforms.
So in your applications today, you as developers
can add support for this stuff today on Gingerbread.
>>Nick Pelly: We'll take a question from the
Google Moderator.
Are we going to have a way of using NFC in
the emulator?
And that's something that we get asked a lot.
And I think, you know, for right now, we really
encourage you to buy a Nexus S and use it
with real hardware. But we are working on
it for the emulator. And hopefully soon.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yeah, I think that the problem
with the emulator is they're -- as we saw
with that diagram, there are so many different
technologies that exist in the realm of NFC.
And it's very difficult to support all of
those simultaneously in the emulator. So that's
something we're working on.
>>Nick Pelly: Question from the front.
>>> So the lack of card emulation support,
does that mean you can't do mobile payments
with NFC as it's implemented in Gingerbread?
>>Nick Pelly: It means that you can't do mobile
-- you can't do mobile payments with the APIs
available in Gingerbread.
>>> And are you planning to add that in for
Ice Cream Sandwich?
>>Nick Pelly: It's something that we're not
going to rule out.
>>> What's the sort of missing pieces there
that you're looking for to make that what
you call a compelling environment to enable
that?
>>Jeff Hamilton: At an API level, you mean?
>>> I think, if I understood, you were saying
it's just not a compelling proposition right
now. What are the missing pieces to make it
compelling?
>>Nick Pelly: The problem is that the hardware
out there today, you know, if you buy an NFC
controller, it typically is only going to
be able to emulate one of those RF-level technologies.
So as an application developer, you don't
know which -- when it's getting deployed to
a phone, which one is on the phone. So I guess
until we see the industry standardize around
maybe one RF-level technology or until we
see NFC controllers able to support multiple
of those. I guess we're actually hoping that
everyone will just move to peer-to-peer or
NDEF exchange, because that removes this problem
entirely.
>>> Looking for a standard in the frequency
supported?
>>Nick Pelly: In the modulation of the -- they
all do 13.56 megahertz, but they have different
modulation schemes.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Take a question from the
back mike.
>>> Okay. I understand this is peer-to-peer
and very close communication. But for the
passive tag reading-wise, I don't think there
is any restriction for, like, reading two
devices at the same time for the passive tag.
Is it true or is it not?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Currently, the Nexus S only
supports reading one passive tag in the field
at a time.
There are a few technical limitations in place.
And more than that, you know, we think there's
really just a user interaction limitation
there where, you know, as we talked about,
we thought -- we think it's very important
for the users to go directly to the application
handling the tag they're interacting with
for that instant gratification. So if the
stack is handling two tags at once, if they
both have NDEF payload, it's not clear what
activity is going to be launched.
>>> Right, right.
>>Jeff Hamilton: So we really think that the
best part of NFC is that it's just kind of
-- it instantly happens for the user. And
so for that reason, right now, you know, we
only support one --
>>> Who is handling those sequences, basically.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Who is handling that sequence?
>>> Yeah. If you have a passive tag and then
both reaches at the same time, who is --
>>Jeff Hamilton: So if you have two passive
tags in the field, it's going to arbitrarily
pick, you know, one to be the first tag. And
I think that depends on the ID of the tag.
And the way it works is a polling loop. So
the radio in the phone will look to see what
exists in the field. And I think that kind
of depends on which tag ends up responding
first in the field. It's pretty arbitrary.
>>> Okay. Thanks.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yep.
>>Nick Pelly: Maybe a question from Google
Moderator.
Is Google going to partner with somebody to
bring real-world NFC use? E.g. mobile payments.
For mobile payments, nothing to announce.
I think -- you know, we're looking at peer-to-peer,
and we're looking at bringing 0-click sharing
to Ice Cream Sandwich. And these are what
we see as the use cases today.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Okay. Question from the first
mike.
>>> Is there a type of NFC tag that allows
an administrator only to write to it?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yes. There are different
levels of encryption, authentication support
in the tags that we talked about.
Some of the tags support doing authentication
using a shared key. And they have different
access control rights in them. So the tags
that you have actually do support that. And
they're using the default keys. So what you
can do is you can authenticate with the tag,
using a -- you know, a shared key, and, you
know, that might give you, based on the access
control, rights to modify the tag, where,
you know, if you don't have that administrator
key, you would only have rights to read from
the tag.
>>> And that's type one that does that?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Type four, I know, does that.
It depends on the product specifically. So
the MIFARE Desfire definitely supports that.
Type one and two I don't believe do that.
Type one and two are simpler tags. They have
smaller data storage. They're also a lot cheaper
as well.
But type four, if you get the MIFARE Desfire,
will do that that. Off the top of my head,
I'm not quite familiar with the exact capabilities
of other products.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Hi. In your examples, you had one phone
ring an application and the other phone was
on the home screen, so it was pretty obvious
when you did peer-to-peer which way that data
transmission was going to happen. What happens
if there's an app running on both, when both
are active and want to share data?
>>Nick Pelly: We're still debating what to
do there, actually. It's a really good question.
>>Jeff Hamilton: So right now, if you have
foreground dispatch enabled in your application,
everything will come to you. So our advice
would be, you know, if you really care about
this in your application, you can -- you know,
you can set up your NDEF push. You can also
enable foreground dispatch. That means while
you're in the foreground, trying to do other
things over NFC, you'll get messages coming,
all the messages inbound, even if they're
not destined for your application. And you
can either drop them on the floor if you want,
or you can indicate to the user that, hey,
I got something from the other side that's
not mine. You might want to do something about
that.
>>> So if there's two separate apps or if
there's the same app running on both phones,
can they exchange information both ways during
that one connection?
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yeah, the data will go both
directions. And it will get dispatched on
the other side, depending on the dispatch
stuff we talked about earlier.
If you're going to go with the NDEF push,
we suggest also going with the foreground
dispatch, and then you have control over the
inbound stuff while you're expecting to do
NFC transactions with another phone.
>>Nick Pelly: Okay. To Google Moderator.
Can I add an adapter to my cell phone to support
NFC?
And the answer is, yes. We just showed it.
But we had to hack up the kernel, so --
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yeah, it was a bit of a hack.
So there aren't any existing adapters today.
Maybe someone will build one with the Android
hardware developer kit announced earlier today,
hopefully.
What you can do is you can get stickers that
are designed to be put on the backs of phones.
And there are special stickers that have,
like, a ferrite shielding on them because
the stickers have antennas in them and they're
pretty sensitive to the other radios in the
phone. So if you're interested in doing interactions
with phones, you can put a sticker on the
back. And, obviously, you can't update the
content of the sticker from non-NFC phones,
but you could do something like put in Bluetooth
addresses of the phone on that sticker on
the back of it.
Question from the first mike.
>>> How durable are the tags themselves? Would
they be wearable and washable?
>>Nick Pelly: I think you should keep that
tag on for a few days and see.
>>> If I wanted to put the tag on my back
pocket and be slapped by a phone, would that
be possible.
>>Jeff Hamilton: It depends. Basically, the
tags are a little IC on here as well with
an antenna. And then that's all kind of packaged
together. There are lots of different people
doing different types of packaging. So right
now, you know, you can get stickers. You can
get, you know, stickers like I talked about
with the ferrite shielding on them specifically
for cell phones. There are people doing things
that you can put on CD cases to do renting
movies, that kind of stuff.
>>Nick Pelly: I think some people are working
on washable NFC tags that you can embed into
clothing similar to inventory tracking tags.
I think we'll see those coming soon.
Question from the back.
>>> Suppose a user is writing to one of the
tags that you provided and the payload is
nearing the limit, the two kilobytes or whatever.
Given the amount of bandwidth available, it
can take several seconds to do that right.
Is there anything in the API to ensure the
integrity of that data or do you have to kind
of roll that yourself, or --
>>Jeff Hamilton: What you can do is -- the
code snippet we had was pretty simple. When
you get the reference to the tag in the field,
you can query it to see what its capacity
is. So what you can do is check to see, you
know, is your data payload larger than the
capacity of the tag. And you can check that
up-front.
Beyond that, you know, when you get -- basically,
if the tag, say it leaves the field while
you're in the middle of doing that operation,
you would get, like, an I/O exception thrown
to your application.
What exactly the state of the tag is at that
point, I'm not sure, probably depends on the
specific tag technology that you're writing
to.
>>> Gotcha.
>>Nick Pelly: Okay. Question from Google Moderator.
Will developers be getting access to the secure
element?
>>Jeff Hamilton: So this one kind of goes
almost hand in hand with card emulation.
Typically, the hardware is set up to do card
emulation through the secure element.
Right now, we don't have any APIs to talk
to the secure element. And we think that we
probably won't be getting APIs to do that
anytime in the near future in the SDK.
There are a bunch of different reasons. Again,
the secure element is a very limited resource.
It can't hold a large amount of data in there.
And if we open it up to any third-party application,
there's going to be a huge resource contention
over the secure element.
Additionally, to talk to the secure elements,
even from applications on the phone, you need
to authenticate yourself properly.
And if you improperly authenticate yourself
a certain number of times, there are secure
elements out there that will physically destroy
themselves and can never be recovered. So
that's something that we really think would
be a bad experience for users, and we don't
want developers getting blamed for, you know,
breaking hardware. It would be tough to know
which application did it. We think it would
be a very bad situation. So today, you know,
we don't have APIs for that. And there are
some constraints that make it tough to create
APIs in the SDK for any third-party application
to talk to the secure element.
>>Nick Pelly: Question from the front.
>>> I know you said that card emulation isn't
going to be supported anytime soon and that
it's because of all the legacy reasons. But
are there any vendors out there today that
are building payment solutions that are based
on peer-to-peer or, you know, NDEF so that
we can actually, you know, take our phones
to local Starbucks and pay for coffee, you
know, using Nexus S?
>>Nick Pelly: I really hope so. I'd love to
see peer-to-peer used for payment technology
-- used for payment.
I think NDEF and peer-to-peer are the way
to go going forward.
>>> But are you aware of anything that's already
in the works?
>>Nick Pelly: No.
>>> And second question, and this may be irrelevant,
but I know it's only on while the screen is
on. But what are the power or battery effects
of having the NFC enabled?
>>Nick Pelly: It's about five milliamps in
polling mode. So it's pretty negligible compared
to the back light.
>>> Okay.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Question from the back mike.
>>> I am just curious. What's the smallest
footprint size of the NFC stickers or tags
that you've seen? Is it pretty much like that
technology requires it to be that big?
>>Jeff Hamilton: The smallest I've seen is
30 millimeter round, which is actually pretty
small if you look at it. I think the bigger
the antenna is, you know, the better -- the
longer range you're going to be able to interact
with it.
>>> I see.
>>Jeff Hamilton: But I have seen 30 millimeter
round, which is actually pretty small.
>>Nick Pelly: It's 13.56 megahertz is used
for all NFC technology. So you have some fundamental
constraints on the antenna size, especially
when you're powering a passive target.
>>> Thank you.
>>Nick Pelly: Going to Google Moderator, does
the Google NFC team see value in the intersection
of NFC and identity? If so, what in the present
set of APIs is useful for NFC-based identity?
I mean, I think we see value for NFC all over
the place. And, you know, not -- not only
specifically an identity, but for so many
different use cases. And, you know, we're
not going to be able to explore all of those.
We're trying to put together the APIs for
developers to try and build apps themselves.
And I guess specifically the APIs available
presently while there's the low-level APIs
for, you know, transceiving to any tag. So
there are some tags that have secure storage
on the tag. You can use low-level APIs to
actually interact with those. Or, you know
-- all the APIs we presented to you today
are around NDEF.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Question from the front.
>>> Actually, the four record type definitions
in standards, but you didn't mention about
the generic controls. So when are you going
to support that?
>>Jeff Hamilton: We don't have support for
it today. We don't actually have plans for
supporting that right now in the dispatching
mechanism. So if you're building an application,
you can get the technology level and you can
look at that, and you could interact with
the -- you know, the -- at the technology
level and get the NDEF off the tag.
>>> So could a vendor define their own, you
know, generic, you know -- the control for
their own sake?
>>Jeff Hamilton: So for -- you can define
that. It just wouldn't get dispatched using
the NDEF-discovered intent.
And part of the reason there is that the specification
there doesn't fit very well into the Android
intent system. So it's not a great way to
map that into intents and allow applications
to filter properly.
>>> Okay.
>>Nick Pelly: So I think we'll just take one
more question, then we're out of time. But
we're available in the office hours afterwards,
and hopefully tomorrow.
So one more from the back.
>>> Okay. I just wanted to ask about the critical
mass issues.
So, basically, you're talking about hardware
here. This is not like a QR code where anyone
can print one out in a home machine. A, can
I just go down to a store and buy a roll of
NFC stickers.
B, there's going to be a period of time in
which people get frustrated when they try
to hold two phones together and nothing happens,
because the NFC support is not implemented
yet in 100% of the apps.
So how do you get from here to critical mass?
Will there be a symbol on the screen of apps,
like a standard symbol that says, "I support
NFC"? How do you get to critical mass and
overcome the hardware issues especially? Because
these things, you can't just make them out
of thin air.
>>Jeff Hamilton: The first question, if you
look on the Internet, you can't just go to
a Best Buy or a Fry's or something and just
pick up a roll of stickers today. There are
vendors on the Internet that will sell them
to you. They're not super easy to come by
today. We're hoping that will change as NFC
gets deployed in more phones and more consumers
are starting to interact with the technology.
Additionally, you know, for the second question,
you know, I think -- you know, we've added
it to the Nexus S, and we're really hoping
that people find value in the technology and
developers started adding support for it to
their applications and then more OEMs will
add NFC support to their hardware.
In terms of identifying which applications
have NFC support in there, we've been toying
around with some ways to try to expose that
information to the user. But we don't really
have anything specific to announce today.
>>Nick Pelly: I think it's the chicken and
the egg problem. And I guess we're the chicken.
>>Jeff Hamilton: Yeah. All right.
Well, we're out of time now. So thank you,
everyone, for coming. We appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>>Jeff Hamilton: And we'll be in office hours
if you have more questions.
>>Nick Pelly: Thanks a lot.